das ist ein glas vollbildmodus ok kraft
herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
leute ich bin mal wieder vor der kamera
und ich habe große nachrichten und zwar
wäre ich im februar jeden tag ein video
für euch hochladen
die motivation dafür habe ich gefasst
als ich einfach über die feiertage
festgestellt habe was machst du
eigentlich mit deinem leben steht
irgendwie die ganze zeit und wenig
eigentlich youtube-videos nach aber es
ist nicht das habe ich mir die challenge
gesagt falls ich frage warum fährst du
damit nicht sofort an
ich habe jetzt im januar noch einige
klausuren und sachen für die uni zu tun
wie ihr vielleicht studiere ich ja auch
noch und deshalb fahre ich am ersten
februar an bis dahin kommen auch schon
packt ihre videos aber dann ging es los
jeden tag videos so ich hab zwar scheint
vor dem titel gesehen ich habe ja auch
leute wieder etwas cooles überlegt und
zwar habe ich dieses gerät hier gekauft
also das ganze heißt livestrong personal
water filter und wach das ist es ist ein
wasserfilter den man mit diesem coolen
ding hier um den hals tragen kann und
dass sie dann auch total schule aus
deshalb reicht es nicht mal zeigen was
geht das im prinzip einfach so ein
modisches accessoire das kann man auch
kaufen dann sind hier über außen herum
sind diamanten und brillanten und bis
heute der 21
ja was ist möglich ist das ist soweit
bedingen würde ich fast sagen also das
ist für leute die beispielsweise einen
roadtrip mit fahrrädern durch den wald
machen und sie haben kein wasser mehr
scheiße werden wir ertrinken werden wir
unter umständen woche sagen kriegen
belboon ist fall trinken
dafür ist dass daten wenn man wirklich
irgendwo in der rede des unterwegs ist
man kann das eine theoretisch das leben
retten weil der wildnis ist schwer
vorstellbar wie diesen problemen mit
ergebnis kann es passieren dass man kein
trinkwasser mehr hat und wenn man dann
wasser trinkt was zum beispiel durch
bakterien verunreinigt ist kann man sich
eine krankheit ohren und potenziell
daran stören und dieses gerät hier
klappt man hier unten auf dann kann man
es in einfluss zum beispiel halten
profis und deckel abziehen und dann aus
dem fluss trinken es werden nämlich
99,9999 99 99 und 9 prozent der
bakterien entfernt stellvertreter mit
dem stern wegen der 0,0001 prozentig
wahrscheinlichen bakterien das wäre
bitter dieses ding hier wittert 4000
liter wasser dieses ein ding das hat
bekanntlich ganz ohne probleme in den
längeren tritt damit machen und dann
einfach sich wie dieser schiller hier an
seen oder flüsse hängen und daraus
hätten ganz wichtig ist dabei natürlich
auch die sonnenbrille wird natürlich
vielleicht auch nur mit sonnenbrille
darauf dringen sowie ab und ich habe für
den test einige sachen gekauft mit denen
jetzt mal testen die man wahrscheinlich
auch zum teil ich soll der welt
wir haben eine ice t eine horn china
nichts davon ist gespannt weil sonst war
ein kölsches wasser in grün und eine
tomate und wir werden natürlich auch den
original test machen uns einfach direkt
mit wasser nehmen und das probieren
vielleicht ja vielleicht wenn dieser ist
hier zu wasser wenn ich darauf trinken
muss ich ja mal probieren ob sich im
geschmack etwas verändern
esther süss wird ständig kurz nach wir
sondern im echten leben
ich habe verpackt verdursten wasser
potenziell kontaminiert zum glück habe
ich nur einen livestream dabei dann
hänge ich jetzt einfach den livestream
in den rhein und probiere die
flüssigkeit entlastet was lernt es noch
nicht bei mir angekommen
man erkennt immer noch das ist aber der
schmeckt deutlich weniger süß und würzig
sowieso ein verrückter daran aber das
kommt wirklich nichts mehr raus was
passiert dann muss man das ist ja jetzt
alles drin glaubt oder ich musste mal
rein
der 1
stellt euch jetzt wieder rausgekommen
ist voll seine farbe verloren
es funktioniert wirklich an der schmeckt
auch gut so wie wasser das nächste mal
diese flüssigkeit mit grün ist auch
ziemlich einfachen und lässiges
das war dann so ein schicksal von hat
man kann auch so mädels ansprechen und
sagen ja ich hab halt auch so ein ding
der ist uns vielleicht das leben retten
könnte wenn in der wildnis wert kurz
aufgebahrt manchmal für die mails ich
kenne jetzt mal einen strohhalm da rein
nun probieren ist es einfach überhaupt
nichts gekommen und habe wirklich
versucht okay leute scheinbar
funktioniert es mit kohlensäure gar
nicht oder ich probiere es nochmal ein
letztes mal richtig tief rein
es funktioniert gar nicht sollte um zu
testen ob ich das nicht jetzt nicht
gerade kaputt gemacht das probiere ich
jetzt einfach noch mal mit wasser also
mit gefahren im wasser
[Musik]
jetzt funktioniert ist tatsächlich ein
richtiger sport funktioniert ja okay
sagt jetzt gerade überhaupt nicht
funktioniert mit kohlensäure und ich
habe eigentlich zwei sachen gekauft mit
kohlensäure und das manchmal zu testen
das ich nehme jetzt einfach mal man da
liegen sagt marin saft trinken hat die
leute die coole rinder sollen wir die
autos ab bringt so
das bistum werde noch ein bisschen
fruchtfleisch das war das heißt live
wird das brauche aber ich bin mal
gespannt ob er überhaupt was durchkommt
bei mais her sind echt überrascht dass
das kaum auch süßwaren sowie so leid
heißt je nachdem man es getrunken hat
und jetzt stelle ich mir das ganze mal
mit orangensaft aus oha ohne wird das
ist so vom geschmack her als hätte man
so ein glas wasser in das man so scheibe
branche sagt rein gelegt hätte das hat
ja nix mehr mit orangensaft zu tun ist
es auch übertrieben anstrengend zu
trinken aber das ist ohne witz so
viehbacher mit der orden steine und
hätte nur mehr wie so ein richtig süßes
brot und sagt und dass ich kraft wenn er
eine marienbaum vorbeilaufen kein wasser
habt dann nehmt einfach die mandarin
macht sie zu sagt trinke ich mit einem
strohballen weil es wahrscheinlich das
beste was wir machen können so leute und
jetzt das szenario das wahrscheinlich am
häufigsten ist vorher letztes glas
wasser das er in der wohnung hat gefragt
oder livestream zufälligerweise rund um
den hals dann geht jetzt für
zimmerpflanzen einfach so eine gute gabe
erde dann passiert es euch dass ihr die
erde in das glas reinmacht weil ihr so
tollpatschig seiten man kennt das glaube
ich also richtig ordentlich so damit ihr
nicht verdurstet müsst ihr das trinken
leute das ist ein glas voll mit
schmutzig verrühren
ich glaube das ist ein ganz schöner
vertrauensbeweis in dieses produkt sie
das jetzt so trinken werde ich riskiere
jetzt mein leben für euch derzeit muss
die mich eigentlich lachen fügt sich das
mal genauer an mit diesen ganzen
partikel wiederum würde man
wahrscheinlich so sonst nicht trinken
ich probiere es jetzt einfach strom sein
und wird geht
ok kraft
das schmeckt nicht mal mehr oder so und
schon gar nicht habe ich irgendwas im
mund also das funktioniert wirklich
passiert echt jede menge dreck drin aber
man kann ja riesig drauf trinken das ist
wirklich cool würdet ihr sonst riefen
flüssigkeit trinken freunde
ich verabschiede mich mit einem
christlichen schlug dreckwasser ich
finde es wirklich cool also ist eine
gute erfindung macht auch wirklich sehen
wenn man irgendwie aus wie nennt man das
aber so diese wanderschaft
das macht natürlich sind aber auch so
ein survival trip unterwegs ist sogar so
roman unter dem sternenhimmel grillt und
so absolute empfehlung von mir ist echt
interessant und ich gehe jetzt weiter
dreck wasser trinken